We have major, a major news to discuss today
of Prince Harry and Meghan have announced
where they will be vacationing at the end
of the year.
No, obviously not.
Don't worry.
This is still the David Pakman show.
There's a ton to say about the real news,
which is we had our first full day of Donald
Trump impeachment inquiry hearings.
And on the one hand there is a lot to say.
And then on the other hand, there isn't that
much to say in a sense.
Um, I'll explain what I mean by that.
The highlight or, or the low light depending
on your proclivity, was that Donald Trump
had an absolute and total breakdown on Twitter
as basically everything that has been asserted
so far about the Trump Ukraine fiasco was
corroborated with some new, uh, allegations
and assertions made, which we will, we will
get to a little bit later on in the program.
Uh, Donald Trump spending the entirety of
the just hour after hour after hour, impeachment
hearings, I think running about six hours
in total, a tweeting Trump tweeting a total
of by my account 26 times during the impeachment
hearings.
Clearly panicked and clearly erratic and clearly
furious.
But at the same time, clearly not understanding
the content of the impeachment inquiry hearings,
which we will also talk about because if I
were to top level it for you, if someone watched
nothing of the hearings yesterday and I had
seven seconds to tell them what happened,
I would say everything that has been asserted
so far was corroborated.
And even worse, allegations were made or even
more incriminating things were, were said.
Um, and, and that is of course, uh, what we,
uh, gleaned from the best recollection of
the two witnesses.
What we've heard so far from the whistleblower
and from Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Veneman
and from Gordon Sunland and the whole host
of them was corroborated.
So let's refresh and we'll get to Donald Trump's
tweets.
Yesterday was day one of the Trump and punishment
inquiry hearings.
Tomorrow, Friday will be day two during which
we will hear from Marie Javon of itch.
Yesterday we heard testimony from William
Taylor, the former us ambassador to Ukraine,
and George Kent, the top Envoy to Ukraine.
Now, the thing about the hearings was that
they were long and they were slow and they
were detailed and they were by the standards
of 2019 low attention span.
Dopamine hit media culture.
They were boring and they were complicated.
Everything that causes Donald Trump and his
followers to think that nothing happened here.
It's a nothing burger.
It was nonsense.
It was old guys talking in circles about nothing,
but if you paid attention, you would have
noticed that the questions from Democrats
who were actually trying to learn something
were answered with clear corroborations of
the story as it's been told thus far.
There was context, there was history, there
were all of these things that don't make great
clips for a five o'clock and 11 o'clock news,
but the quid pro quo, the expectations from
Trump of Ukraine, the military aid, so on
and so forth, all corroborated thanks to the
questioning of Democrats along with some grandstanding
as well.
I completely admit now, the Republican questions
were almost postmodern, simply repeating vague
epistemological questions because they could
not actually put together a line of questioning
that pointed to anything other than attempted
bribery by Donald Trump and the people around
him.
Can you think of something and be wrong about
your opinion?
Could you misinterpret the intentions of someone
else?
Haven't people been wrong before about what
they believed happened?
And as I tweeted yesterday for a group that
claims to be against postmodernism and relativism,
so ardently Republicans had nothing to go
to other than these hypothetical's about how
do we know what we know?
Can we know anything?
Is anything really knowable is true because
they had nothing else to understand.
Republican questions.
At yesterday's impeachment hearings, you also
had to understand a lot of viral Facebook
nonsense because a lot of the lines of questioning
from Republicans that focused on impugning
people's character, character assassination,
so on and so forth.
If you were not up to speed on popularly shared
fake news articles and Facebook memes and
conspiracy theories, you wouldn't even understand
where it was.
Republicans were trying to go with their questions
yesterday.
Uh, and because of this, of course, uh, that
is the defense that they are going with.
Uh, they try to remind their low information
supporters that even though the witnesses
are being completely consistent in their testimony
and they're corroborating what's already been
alleged, everyone might just be misremembering
or misinterpreting things.
That is effectively the defense that they
tried to frame up.
It's not really a defense, but sadly, Donald
Trump fell for it.
And that means Donald Trump's followers will
fall for it.
And think that yesterday was merely just,
Hey, this is people saying things that could
be wrong.
And that's it.
So then we get to Donald Trump's tweets just
completely all over the place.
And again, how does a president have this
much time to tweet lots of retweets of lunatic
extremist content.
For example, a video of absolutely bonkers
Republican Jim Jordan asking questions with
some bogus talking points from Republicans
on the oversight committee.
A retweet of a big sign claiming that Adam
shift learned the identity of the whistle
blower 93 days ago, which is not only untrue,
it's also irrelevant.
But again, we have time.
We'll get to that a little bit later.
A re tweeting a video, obviously from Fox
news show, Fox and friends were extremist
Republican, Kevin McCarthy.
McCarthy calls this entire impeachment hearing
process.
A sham.
What is Trump doing all day that he sends
out tweet after tweet after tweet nearly 30
tweets during a six hour hearing.
And speaking of Fox news, by the way, because
Fox news was the subject matter of a lot of
Donald Trump's tweets and retweets, Fox news
is now fully back on the Trump bandwagon as
far as yesterday's coverage goes, covering
the impeachment hearings by defending Trump,
by gaslighting viewers with completely bogus
side-by-side a biographical information about
Adam Schiff and William Taylor.
And we'll talk about some of those bogus,
misleading graphics that Fox news put up.
Um, a little bit later in the show.
But first we need to deal with a bigger picture
issue in general with these hearings and the
Trump suffocation of media.